ﾊｲｨ!
皆さん、お待たせしましたぁ～
はじめしゃちょーの質問コォ↓ナー↑
10月(謎の隙間)版でございます！
＼ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ／
今回はですね、今までと違いまして
Youtubeの方のコメント
と↑
Twitterの方のコメント
2つの質問、リクエスト頂いております。
なのでｴｯﾄｫ
合計すると物凄い数のそのね？
質問やらリクエスト頂いた事
まずは！
感謝申し上げます！ありがとうございます！
Youtube版
と↑
Twitter版の動画を2つ、
作ろうと思っております。
で、とりあえず今回はYoutube版ですね
ちなみに！
「なんなんですか？」って質問には
今回答えておりま・・・
せん！(爽やかSmile.)
では行こう！
＼ﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞｰﾝ／
採用です!!
（沈黙TIME.）
今度からは...質問しようね...?
僕は地下鉄じゃないですね～
ｶｴﾚｪｰｲ!
僕は～靴ではないですね～
x3
x4
x5
x6
ﾊｯ...
ありがとうございます。
ｳｰwwｱｰｱｧｰwwｳｰｱｰｱｰｧwwww
ｳﾞｰwwwｳﾞｪｰｳﾞｪｰｳﾞwｳﾞwｳﾞwｳﾞwｨ
ﾋﾟｮｳｨｰﾝwwﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹww
ﾀｰﾝﾃｰﾎﾞｰｼﾞｬｰﾝｹｪｰｲwww
ﾌｧｰﾝwwﾌｧﾝﾀﾞﾛwwﾌｪｰﾝ
ｽwﾎﾟwwﾎﾟwﾎﾟwﾎﾟwﾎﾟwﾎﾟｫｰﾝwww
ﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾚﾍﾟﾚﾍﾟﾝwwww
ﾒﾁｬwwﾑﾁｮwwﾒﾁｮﾑwwﾁｬﾑwwﾁｪwwwww
ﾄﾝwﾄﾝwﾄﾝwﾄﾛﾄﾞﾙﾙﾙwwﾀｧｰﾝwww
ｳｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝwwwwww
ﾃﾚwﾃﾝwﾃﾚwﾃﾝwﾃﾃwﾍﾟﾝwﾃﾃwwﾍﾟﾝww
無
ﾍｪﾔｯﾌｫｵｵｵｵｵｨwwwﾎｲﾔﾌｫｵｵｵｵｲｧwwwwww
FUHAHAHAHAHAHA
馬鹿にしてんの？
すいませんでした。
(鼻をすする音)
ﾎﾜｧｧｧｧｵ
ｲﾀｯ  ﾔﾊﾞｲ
(悲鳴time.)
お前のせいだぞ！
Youtube!
大丈夫ですよ、あの
コメント採用されない人もちゃんと僕
コメント見てますから！
安心してください
(ヒ・ミ・ツ💛)
来んなよ
なんでこんな聞きたがるの!?ww
立てるわ、バカヤロー
これどうすればi
僕も不登校という訳じゃないんですけども
実は、夏休み前から学校に行ってませんでした。
あっ、サボってた訳じゃないよ？
不登校でもないですよ？
もう授業が足りてるんで
授業が一個もなかったんで学校行ってなかったんですけど
学校にも行ってないし
夏休みも学校行ってなかったんで
久しぶりに学校に行くのがすっごい怖かったです
理由があって不登校になってるかも知れないんですけども
僕も夏休み明けに久しぶりに学校行った時は
ﾓｫ‐
変な汗めっちゃ掻きながら行ってたんで
すっげえ行きづらい気持ちはわかるんですけど
行っちゃえばなんとかなると思います！
くまモン...
諦 め ん な よ ! ! !
この俺を舐めてもらっちゃあ困る、
靴下なんてもんは余裕で全部食べてやる...
ｴ"ｳﾞｴｪｪｪｪ
ｳﾞｫﾜｧｧｧｧｧ!!
ｵｫｫｫｳ!!
ｵｵｫｫｫ!
ｾﾝｶﾞｰﾝ!
ｳｵｰ
ｷｶﾞｴﾀﾞｧｰｰ!!!
ﾊﾞｧｧｧｧ!!
ﾄﾞｳﾞｫｰﾝ!!
ｳｫｼ
出えぇえぇ来たああああぁぁぁァァァァ!!!
ｲwﾔwｯwﾊwｧｰｳwwwww
ｴｯﾍｯﾍwwwwﾍｯﾍｯﾍwwｲｨwｰﾋｨwｰwｰwｰｰww
ｴｯﾋｲ↓ｳﾞｨｲｨｲ↓wwwwww
これでいい？
まぁコメント沢山あって読むのは大変なんですけど
皆さんのコメントがないと成り立たない動画でございます！
本当にコメントしてくださった皆さん、ありがとうございます！
バカ野郎解除してんじゃねえか！
ただの暴力じゃん( ´・ω・｀)
もうちゃんと「痛い!」って友達に言ったほうがいいよ？
それか、倍 返 し に し て 、返　し　て　や　れ　！
馬鹿野郎、鰹節じゃねえわ！
鰹節じゃ
ねぇわ！
いい精神科の病院、教えますよ？
いつも適当ですね
ネットでﾊﾟﾊﾟｯって買うときもあるし
人が多いのが
お店で買うのがニガテなんで、
閉店ギリギリの服屋さんに飛び込んで
ﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯって店員さんと話し合いながら買ってます
ブランドとかあんま興味ないんで
なんか着たい物着てます
(プレイ中)
ﾑ ﾘ ﾀﾞ ﾛ ! !
ゑ？なんか言った？
えっ!?何～!?誕生日プレゼントあるの!?
えっ!?何?えっ?何!?
えっ↑?えっ↑↑?
(言葉に出来ない悲しみ)
ありがとう(ﾀﾞﾝﾃﾞｨｳﾞｫｲｽ)
ありがとうございます！
適当に頑張ります！
ｳﾞｳｧｯﾌﾟｧ!!!
コレのためにパンパースを買った俺を褒m
あぁ、お前かい...
あっすいません
今救急で精神科の方って今空いてますか？
ｳﾞｫｲ!
髪の毛がなぁ
ワックスとか痛むからあんま付けたくないんスよね～...
いじめが何故起きるかと言うと
性格の違いとか、能力の違いとかが
原因で起きることがありますね
いじめって言うのは
我々が個性とかね、能力の差があるから起きることであって
もし俺達が皆
同じ人間、同じ性格、同じ能力だったら
いじめは無くなると思います。
皆が皆、違うからいじめが起きてしまう。
だから『いじめ』って言うのはね
皆が同じ能力、同じ性格でない限り
必ず起きる事です。
だからと言って「いじめはしていい物か」と言っても
そうではないんだよね。
いじめが無くなる事はないと思うけども
いじめが無くなるように努力する事が
大切だと僕は思います。
ﾋﾟﾋﾟｭｰﾎﾟﾝ
はい、という事でいかがだったでしょうか！
質問コーナー(YouTube.ver)!
ホントに沢山のコメント皆さんありがとうございました!!
二回ね、同じ奴が続くとちょっとアレなんで...
来週、Twitterの質問コーナーをやろうと思います!
本当に皆さんたくさんの質問ありがとうございました！
じゃあなッ
Twitter.verもはじめんの「質問コーナー」の動画リストから
視聴する事ができます！
次回の動画もお楽しみに！
チャンネル登録や、SNSの共有などもしてくれるとはじめんが喜びます！